welcome to labor District council's
planning committee I will now ask the
government's officer to read out the
domestic Arrangement and the fire
thank you chair please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use please do not interrupt other people
speakers or hold separate conversations
whilst others are speaking
if you're attend the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off and that your
laptop is also switched to silent
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and we're capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
council members of the public and the
Press May film record photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
you hear the fire alarm please leave the
building immediately via a fire exit and
make your way to the assembly point
which is Ipswich Town training ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exit at each ends at the floor do
not enter the atrium if you're in the
atrium the time the fire alarm follow
the signs to the nearest fire exit use
the stairs not the lifts and please do
not re-enter the building until told it
is safe to do so thank you chair
thank you Claire some introductions with
us today are Mark Russell the area
planning manager our legal advisor is
even to pray the case officers Harry
Goodrich
Governors officer you've just met his
Claire the economic development officer
is clear free thank you Claire I to
introduce the new Vice chair Helen Davis
is here and I'm Stephen from your chair
for today
moving on do we have any apologies for
absence
substituting thank you are you married
to receive declarations disclosure
peculinary interest and other
registerable and non-registered interest
by members are there any declare
no thank you
Declarations of lobbying are there any
to declare
Council bill
asked a question on two on three and
four when did we decide to add this to
the agenda
um was this a decision taken by yourself
after consultation
um
I know a bit Suffolk have this but we've
never had it before and I'm not saying
I'm against it but I would have felt
that we should have had
um consultation on this but these two
particular items to suddenly find that
on the agenda uh you're just somebody's
dictating to us this is what's got to
happen now if you tell me it's a
government directive
or another one fair enough but um I
don't think it's rather bad that we were
not consulted
thank you
as far as I'm concerned it was a
governance directive
Claire would you like to fill in a bit
more
they uh if there was a Freedom of
Information Act we'd now be able to just
um sorry request we'd now wish to be
able to look back at the minutes and see
who'd been lobbied and who'd be having
um so that's that's the right reasons
they've just been added on there
um come back Mr chairman yes I
understand that and I agree
wholeheartedly with you but I still like
to know why it suddenly came in now we
never had it before uh it's
um let me finish now
I'm not sure if it is I'd like to know
all the information about that thank you
it was taken on board as it's a new
Council after an election it is on the
advice of the government's officers and
I have no objection to doing so and I'm
not going to argue the case anymore
thank
you but who that's my I want to answer
to the question is that who decided to
put it on I'd like information on it
please simple as that
I'm not against it but I'd like to know
how we got to this stage you know
otherwise that you can just impose
anything tell us it's a directive
agenda at the chairs breathing and the
chair was happy am I happy happy to do
so
the answer was it was an officer's
decision after discussion with yourself
and you thought it was acceptable I'm
more than happy now you've explained all
that difficult to get to this result
I just think an email to all committee
members stating the reason for it would
have been preferable but then we
wouldn't have had this discussion
okay thank you
right are there any Declarations of
lobbying
nope okay Declarations of personal site
visits
anyone visited this site
nope
Right Moving on confirmation of the
minutes of the meeting held on the 5th
of April 2023.
are there any points of accuracy
regarding the minutes
does anyone like to bring up
nope in that case can I move for
approval can I have a proposal please
counselor Holt the secondary Council of
beer
conduct
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
uh I'm aware a lot of you would not have
been at that last meeting
um so I'll ask you to correct me if I'm
wrong but you are able to vote on that
you can abstain or you can vote either
way there is no legal requirement of
which way you just to endorse that yes
indeed it's every every time we have a
voting committee no matter what four
every members are entitled to vote
unless they have a disqualifying
interest it's a local government
tradition there's no more than a
tradition but if you weren't there you
don't vote on the minutes but when we
have a changeover I think that tradition
sometimes can take a back seat so it
members Can Vote or abstain as they see
fit
thank you members that find votes for
and six abstentions so that's carried
it on
any notification of petitions
obviously Chad thank you science
inspection tomorrow
yes chair um
since uh briefing there's been some
change in circumstance we did have two
sites in shotley that we're going to ask
if members could visit but one of those
applications has now been withdrawn that
just leaves one site which is the one
that some members have already visited
so the request was going to come from
officers so we can withdraw the request
for those visits so we have no site
visits
how's it running
um as a new member to this committee if
some members have visited
if it's still coming to committee
wouldn't that be not very good if some
some bits some members have visited and
others will not have
I think that would be the case if the
request had come from a member but
actually no member had requested the
site visit it actually came from the
officers because there were two sites
close to each other we thought while
we're looking at the other one we may as
well look at this one again but now the
other one's gone away that's the
position we're left in
thank you Mark
Right Moving On
to Applications we have
dc2301002 the queen said Queens Road
Irvington
I will now invite to case officer Harry
Goodrich to introduce the application to
the committee
if you know
thank you chair and good morning members
so we are looking at application DC
2301002 at the Queen's head Queens Road
in Irvington
The Proposal itself is for the change of
views from public house within a sewage
generous use to a residential use
falling within C3 it should be noted
that there are no internal nor external
alterations within this application and
we are solely looking at the change of
use of the building itself to to be
within a full C3 use
okay so looking into some site history
there was a previous proposal on the
site for the same scheme that was
refused and then dismissed at appeal the
reason for dismissal is up there up
there in sort of conclusion it related
to
insufficient marketing information
having been submitted to prove that
there was no other Optimum viable uses
for the building
we have now had an agreed marketing
campaign with the economic development
team that's been undertaken
and this is this application has come
forward as a result of that
okay so looking into policy
considerations the key policies we're
looking at here are em24 for the
retention of existing employment sites
cs17 for the rural economy cs01 for
sustainable development and CNA one for
design standards and then looking
forward to the baber mid-suffer Joint
local plan we'll be looking at lp09 and
lp10
so here we have an aerial map showing
the Queen's head itself within a cluster
of residential development
and surrounded by agricultural fields in
a largely rural setting
so we have a site we have the site there
outlined in red showing the public house
with the neighboring property of
broomcot located off to the Northeast
so look at the Straits map we have the
Queen's head itself being grade 2 listed
the footpath running to the north of the
site
the amb to the South and then obviously
further along to the east we have a
grade one listed building and two
further grade two listed buildings
so if we're looking at the top right
picture we have the site location itself
it's about here on the picture and it
shows the Queen's head itself in
relation to the remainder of erworton
off to the side here
the bottom plan here shows the Queen's
head within its car park with its car
parking and access point running up the
side of the site here
and then off to the left here we have
again a block plan showing the Queen's
head with the numerous sort of
extensions flat roofed and
pitched roof extensions that have been
added over time
so looking at some site photos obviously
we have the Queen's head itself here
with the extensions that have been added
on over time
so here we have the Queen's head itself
this sort of the historical core of the
building that's been retained and then
obviously as I've just previously stated
we have a number of sort of extensions
that have been added on over time with
the access point going down the side
so this picture obviously shows the
neighboring property at room cop with
the access point running down the side
of the property and this is obviously
the Queen's head itself
so this is a photo heading away from the
site to the South West it's heading
towards sort of parkstead and then even
further into Holbrook
this is heading to the Northeast heading
out and through our turn into sort of
shotley and the the facilities there
so the key issues we have this
application and it's not a non it's a
non-exhaustive list but it's an
important Community facility a lot of
the Public House impact on local economy
uh Community interest in purchasing the
asset the loss of potential employment
opportunities the public has to be
neglected no attempt to operate the
public house as a business and incorrect
marketing
the application is recommended for
approval subject to the conditions found
in the in the papers
thank you chair
Point Mr
thank you
um yes I just need to make a correction
this this is for sorry I'm dropping
things here
um this is not Harry's fault because
he's done the right thing and reported
to you all the comments of the console
tease if you look at page 11 under SCC
Highway Authority I was just a bit
concerned they refer to C3 residential
use and I highways officers are know
about traffic and highways they're not
planners to be absolutely precise
um
Queen's head like many old pubs has had
residential accommodation within it for
the landlord landlady and their family
that's not C3 that is ancillary
residential accommodation within the
single planning unit of the club so I
just want
to make sure there was no
there was no misunderstanding there
thank you Ian
we also have a gender item Corrections
with table yesterday have you all read
it
and applied it
right I suggest I give you a couple of
minutes now
to read it it's only correct in
grammatical errors isn't it Harry
but that's
should have been emailed to you
yesterday
we've got some paper copies which Beth
can bring around if anybody needs
Mary you okay
thank you very much okay
we'll now move on to questions for the
case officer
councilor Mabry thank you very much Mr
chairman um and thank you
Harry I have two questions first of all
could you bring back the photo
beside the property
okay that one yes is that the gate to
the car park or the gate to separate
and see Lowry
so that's the gate to the car park to
the rear of the site right
right and secondly can you look into me
what incorrect marketing memes
um obviously the the points brought up
on slide 13 in terms of the key issues
were what has been raised from the
consultation we've had with the
community through our site notes and
letters that was a summary of what has
been brought up um
in terms of the incorrect marketing I'll
ask Claire because she might be able to
point in a better direction as to the
the sort of inconsistencies with all the
discrepancies between the marketing
points of view
the
community statement is that the the
their assessment of the marketing
differs to the marketing campaign but we
agreed with the agents and the
applicants at the time in March 2021
without going over all the different
points that of
that's what they mean by incorrect
marketing is they fundamental oh that's
my understanding is that it
fundamentally differs from the agreed
marketing campaign
um yes
um probably to both to both Harry and
declare
um
so
um does this mean that the marketing
strategy is now null and void because it
was incorrect as to what was agreed
sorry is it
but is it was Harry reporting the fact
that people have written in saying they
thought there was incorrect marketing so
that's not the view of the officers so
the if you like members the public are
writing or whoever said that is
expressing concern that the
size is not simply the committee to be
able to in draw a conclusion that
there's no realistic future as a
I think that's the point that's being
made that's been reported to you but
that's not the view of the council's
officers
right thank you so that confirms it's
not the view of offices
right thank you
councilor bear you have a question
I just follow along from that just to be
clear the the marketing that has been
done now is correct they have followed
the correct procedures done the the time
on it or will be up by time so so that
we're clear that we're not talking
that's been undertaken was the marketing
that was agreed with the economic
development team in 2010
councilor Wyman
thank you
the word council at base point and also
to councilor maybe point on the the
marketing
um
there's quite strong anecdotal evidence
through the Publishers
sorry this is yes yes thank you
um
in relation to the marketing
do office holders considered that the
time of the marketing exercise was
appropriate based upon the fact that
we're just coming out of Omicron and
was extremely depressed
thank you
Harry I'll ask Claire to I'm clear if
you wouldn't mind
the marketing campaign was
careful 12 months which is what policy
and is the most the policy can ask for
we push the client to carry out the full
12 months which they did so with it in
that respect the marketing and the price
agreed as
um
the agent that was used was a
responsible and respected Leisure and
Hospitality specialist the terms of the
campaign the price and details and the
way the marketing campaign was carried
out were agreed by officers with the
applicant and the agent at the time and
the campaign was carried out for the
full 12 months as requested that's what
the policy asks for thank you
okay
councilor hope
yeah Harry um can you clarify if the
ancillary accommodation is actually
being used has been used over recent
years or has it been closed off since
the published shut and secondly I think
it would have been useful to see the
back of the building as well just to see
the state of the car park Etc in the
back uh fabrication of the building so
in terms of the first point the
ancillary accommodation we don't have
any information submitted under the
application obviously we can only deal
with what's put in front of us an
application we haven't been provided
with anything to say when the
accommodation was used if it's used
anything like that we've it's got an
ancillary accommodation at first floor
level
um I wouldn't say it's necessary and
Mark may be able to support me it's I
wouldn't say it's an owner so they have
to provide us definitive information
that says that it's used
there and then
Point yeah I've only apologized for the
the lack of a picture to the rear and
the parking space hopefully the aerial
map does enough to
steer there
chairman if one moment okay thanks to
McLaren
thank you chair can I
by the point that the killer Wyman made
I accept always say about
it they fulfill the 12 months
but the comment that counselor Wyman
made was that at the time it was done
was a time of great
changes in the hospitality sector as it
was
it and and
was that ever considered that the fact
that
Hospitality businesses all over the
United Kingdom were struggling and
selling businesses like that can I just
clarify that
um so
price the way marketing campaign is
agreed the agent has to provide evidence
of comparable prices to justify the
price that they are asking for the
property this was done at the time in
March 2021 the market was slightly
better than it is now we're two years
further on it's a different it's a
different picture now but at the time
marketing campaign was agreed it was
slightly different so the the agents
provided evidence of comparable prices
and were confident that that was
appropriate at the time
and we we agreed with that campaign
Mr Grandin
um may I ask Claire about
um Community assets how could she remind
us of how the system works and that kind
of thing please
um
I don't profess to be an expert on acvs
but I do know that in the context of
this case the um the the community did
previously apply to have the property
registered as an ACV but at that time it
had been closed for such a long time it
fell outside of the terms which would
make it appropriate for an ocv so it
didn't get one
thank you can we can I ask when do we
know when the last time it was open as a
public house
I believe it was 2009 but there are
I've heard 14 years mentioned
2009.
come on
this one yeah what's what's it an ACV
ACB I don't know what that is sorry
it's an asset of community value
getting more help on that do you need
I don't think I don't I don't think so
Ian because we've we're in the situation
where it had it's not an ACB so it
hasn't been given an ACV
sorry
um
there
a campaign complete
complete a lot can change in two years
is there any guidance about maybe
repeating a marketing campaign if you
exceed a certain period before
submitting an application following
completion of a marketing campaign
so the campaign was agreed two years ago
and finished a year ago
um and you'll see from my response that
I did say that you know maybe the
relevance of that had been diminished by
the time difference between the campaign
ending and the application coming in
however we have nothing in policy that
asks for uh for there to be a definite
period after a marketing campaign for it
still to be valid so the marketing
campaign stands
thank you
going from Mayberry did you have another
question um yes and I'm sorry to to
bring this up but it is a new committee
here but my colleague here um councilor
Wyman seems to have some extra
information that we don't have
Fold It Up
we don't have that I don't have it
so I don't know what that is
I read from the information in relation
to the points I made about the Omicron
and it was a Doris over I used that
information to to deduce the Omicron
basis of my comment
councilor Weidman was making a general
comment about the effects of the
National Emergency on on the economy and
pubs in particular is that that's very I
think that's fair enough chair not
specific information to this application
thank you
I think that's quite all right thank you
clarison McLaren question
a
question of Harry was this accommodation
the ever used for like bed and breakfast
or so it was the pub accommodation ever
used in a broader sense than just the
public house so looking at the site
history it doesn't look as it was ever
used as sort of a airbn or a b or
anything like that it looks solely been
used in association with the
the public they're running the Public
House itself
if I may have only had the pups can
sometimes do that without Express
planning permission we unless we might
want the applicant or
any of some of the speakers might be
able to assist the committee with the
history more perhaps
thank you Ian
okay
excuse me okay
um
is that now I had to help the person
make the decision okay quick very
quickly there you want to say
I have been used for bed and breakfast
or Airbnb thank you very much
currency register you are um Yes
actually following on from that point
it's a question
um if it has a how come they've uh the
owners have never tried to actually gain
any Revenue by renting out for example
the uh ancillary residential area of the
property which is what other other
people with closed pubs have done I
don't I'm not sure I understand why
that's not happened
I guess the long and short of it is
there's no requirement
for them to necessarily rent out the
space or that they they can own the bill
you know people own buildings all the
time and don't do anything with them
it's
it's unfortunate but I don't think
there's any requirement for them to
necessarily rent out the space
in that sense
sorry I've ever made sure were they to
have done that rented out the rooms and
not run the pub I think we'd have found
ourselves in a change of use situation
there
rooms and scenery to the running of the
pub that probably as Mr Price that
wouldn't need plant compression but if
the pups closed and not running and
they've got rooms upstairs are renting
out I think that would be a material
change of use
thank you
thanks for growing
okay so can I just confirm that the pup
has just stood derelict or empty for
since 2009 doing nothing
on the information we have yes
and we don't know whether the owners
have lived above or not during this we
don't have that information even though
no one's asked
thank you
any more questions for the officer
if not thank you very much Harry
we have
um
representative of the parish meeting I
can't read my own writing I've left here
uh Christine Kyle you have three minutes
to address the commit
Planning Group Overton Parish meeting
the following are the views of the group
and they are broadly the same as those
we gave in our Consulting comments at
the end of March
as the district council elections have
resulted in some changes in the
Personnel of the council it may be
helpful if I sum up now briefly the
story of the Queen's head
the Queen's head named for the close
link that the village has with the life
of Anne Berlin is a fine grade two
listed building in a central location
within the parish
It is believed to have functioned as a
pub since the time it was first built
it has always been well supported in
this role and there are older
parishioners with memories reaching back
to the 1950s ready to verify this
the pub operated successfully under two
owners from around 1979 through to 2006
when some inept decisions over its
future Direction eroded its customer
base
it underwent a complete refurbishment
but failed to rebuild its clientele and
was sold in October 2010.
Pub's new owners announced their plan to
reopen the pub as an ale house coffee
shop and art gallery achieving some
publicity through the East anglian Daily
Times
they confirmed this intention at a
parish meeting however although some
Works were undertaken for this purpose
nothing positive came from their
pronouncements
for the last two years a community Pub
group has been working hard to save the
building as a Community Asset with
strong support from the erworton parish
meeting
there can be no doubt that resurrecting
the Queen's head would bring huge
benefits to the parish
since the late 1980s the building has
had a large extension known as the
orange tree this was built as a dining
area and function room but could also be
useful in other ways for the community
particularly as erberton does not
possess a Village Hall
there have been some 50 objections to
the application for change of use with
only two supporting it in the years
since the Pub's closure The Village has
also gained a significant number of new
houses with more to come which will add
to the Pub's potential customer base
the Overton Parish meetings Planning
Group strongly objects therefore to the
application for a change of use and we
hope very much that committee will
support us the community and refuse it
thank you
representative
councilor Mabry
um thank you very much Mr chairman um if
thank you very much for your report if I
could ask you how many inhabitants are
there in Overton please
126. thank you very much
Council Grandin
thank you chair
um I think I read somewhere in the
report that in the region of over 70 000
pounds has been promised if that's a
word
um where
would that be likely to materialize
would that increase but I'm sure how
this gentleman who is going to speak on
behalf of the save the Overton Queen
Community will be able to give you all
the facts and figures on that one thank
you
any more questions for this speaker
Council register
um what is the nearest other pubs to uh
there are some in shortly and how far is
that that's about a mile and a half away
to two miles I know they're footpaths
too but not directly you would have to
walk along the footpaths that the store
in Orwell path
um or you along the roads yeah
councilor Davis
you told me where your
your Instagram
okay
um is there any um
tell or or other
tourist accommodation in their vicinity
no not in the not in the vicinity no
thank you
no thank you very much we have another
Parish meeting representative I
understand is that correct sir
right okay
fine well the community group you're the
community group so it's Steve Smith the
community group you'll have three
minutes to address the committee thank
you
um I'm here on behalf of the community
group which was trying to turn the or
buy the pub to turn it into a
community-owned business
um I'm here to speak on behalf of the
committee
was chaired by William Lynch local
farmer who happens to be in the canaries
this week
um
the applicants have owned this property
for over 10 years now and they've never
attempted to my to trade from the
property
there was a decision on the handy Cross
Keys a few years back either planning
inspector concluded that where the
reasonable efforts have have or have not
been made to maintain a viable Public
House business is relevant to the
planning decision
and we think those efforts haven't been
made by these owners
we don't believe that the 2021 marketing
of the property was at a price that
reflected its commercial status
it's non-trading history and its state
of disrepair
the agents had used used by the owners
had previously previously produced the
report stating that the business excuse
me was not viable a conclusion not
actually supported by our own
commissioned report
so it doesn't then follow that they
marketed the premises
at 115 000 pounds more than the price
which was paid by the owners
and also stating that the property now
requires in excess of a hundred thousand
pounds of repairs thanks to the current
owners neglect
the marketing campaign has stated in
this chamber took place during a period
of uncertainty in the pub trade in
general thanks to covid
we think the value of a pub is what
someone's willing to pay for it not what
the owners are willing to sell it for
and we think it would like those
circumstances
with an overage clause on the pub as
well
the um the price asked was patently
ridiculous
we're actively working to put in a
community bid for the pub we've got
fantastic levels of support shown
locally
uh but we need more time in order to
secure Government funding from the
community ownership fund and we can't
access this without the pub being for
sale we appreciate
if the application's thrown out they
still don't have to sell it to us but
it'd be nice to have the chance
when the pub was suddenly withdrawn from
the market we tried on numerous
occasions to contact the owners to make
our intentions clear they ignored every
one of those attempts
and we we tried to contact the agents
who told us that it was nothing to do
with them anymore
this lack of communication suggests
there was no genuine attempt to find a
buyer for the business
in short we believe that marketing
campaign was a bit of a sham by the
owners
and the the
Claire's and the committee's conclusion
from 2019 still stands that the argument
has not been fully tested
thank you your time is up thank you
thank you thank you very much
any questions for this speaker
Council register
um
you tell me what the overage Clause was
about and how it worked within the
constraints of the contract
um
can't actually tell you the percentages
but it was a percentage of any uplift in
the value of the property so it for
example if
um if the property was purchased for 200
000 pounds and then sold for 250
it's on time in the future the owners
would gain a
bit about uplift of fifty thousand
pounds
okay thank you
thank you one moment I'm going to ask
Claire to a shooting Time by that point
please
so it's quite standard for an agent to
use an overage Clause because we do that
we agree that's a discourage speculative
residential development because uh
speculative residential interest in a
property because frequently a commercial
property when it hits the market
obviously is not substantially lower for
us than it would be if it was a
residential property so you will get
developers and other people who will buy
a property on the off chance that they
can then sell it on as residential or
develop it as residential later on pubs
are particularly attractive in this
respect because they have car Parks so
you can
um so we we never mind when an agent
uses an overage Clause because we do not
want to be having the same conversation
with another new owner later on down the
line when we tell them that no you can't
just change it to residential you might
have bought it with that intent but it
would it was sold with that intent so we
use the overage Clause to discourage
that speculative interest
does that make it is that
is that it is acceptable for that for
the fact that this health this property
was run down so therefore any uh
if it was then done up and then sold
the average Clause of coming tonight uh
all change changed ownership the overage
Clause were coming to effect even though
it might not be used it might not be
effective
done for the reasons of making it purely
residential the Irish Clause should only
be applied if there is a change of use
so if it was
a commercial use it wouldn't apply but
if it was sold on as residential then
that's when it would cut in so that's
how it discourages speculative
residential development
thank you man
any more questions
thank you
thanks Miss I know that
other Jews you can
you found 75 000 pounds pound or similar
with the
um
of a funding how in your
are you going to is it going to take for
you to achieve that other funding I we
would hope about 18 months
we appreciate it's a long time but the
government wants plans in place they
don't want us
going ahead without getting our ducks in
a row
and I've just got one second question
I haven't said that I forgot I think I
was going to ask
um sorry about that I kind of come back
well if you if you're going through yeah
can you thank you Council Carlton you
have a question
thank you
um I was just uh going to ask about the
time frame and how much longer you
needed for the community bid
um but the money that you're
hoping to get is that just for the
purchase or is that for the repairs as
well
as well it's a bit of everything
um we don't think the repairs are
anywhere near or we don't think we'd
have to pay as much for the repairs as
stated in the
um
the marketing documents simply because
we've got local labor we can use we've
got people on the committee we've got
people within the village who will do
things for us for a little in comparison
with what
Rose Builders who were the people
commissioned by
Herald and Cole
to um produce their estimate
thank you
councilor hold
maybe for Ian but it relates to a
question that or comment the object was
just made the comment there was no
effort has been made to maintain the
building has been neglected in planning
law
is there any way that we could take
comments like that or factual
information like that into account that
if an owner basically neglects it runs
it down
to rack and ruin to the point that
there's no use to anyone anymore rather
than converting it
is there anything in planning law that
gives us a position to argue that and
and fight against it because it seems to
be quite a common thing these days the
villagers have pubs closed and they just
run down neglected
the point that all I can do with it is
have it is residential so is there
anything other than a marketing policy
M24 that we could argue against it
someone is doing that on purpose with a
sole of reason to change your use
understand the point I'll let Harry or
Mark go first and then I'll come in
later if you because that's that's
something you're you're often familiar
with I think
I think a relevant serious effect it's
listed building so if it been left in
such a state that urgent repairs were
required we can use that legislation to
make them uh make the building whether
type weatherproof and actually do any
repairs that are necessary but your
general point about letting a building
slowly degrade let's say
um the the quick answer is is no
is there a longer answer
hahaha
there will be a longer answer which
still end up with saying no
inspectors
don't like situations where something's
been done to bring about a result but
there isn't very much in National local
policy that you could hang a reason to
refuse and I think that's the longer
answer would you agree
thank you Cancer Care others you are
with I suppose this is a question to
both of you really
um when the pub was open how often was
it used for local meetings and functions
I mean I assume it was it regularly used
because I imagine that the church
yeah it was you know does it does and
also does the church does it provide the
same kind of facility there aren't any
facilities in any church there aren't
any lavatories for example in the church
the church is a 13th century building
very beautiful and of course it's grade
one listed so you can't
change that and suddenly add at blues
and kitchens and things like that so it
would be very helpful
so that they're open very quickly
because there's a limited amount of
heating so yeah a point of order Mr
chairman we seem to be debating rather
than asking questions
sort of jumping in well thank you thank
you Mr chairman
have you ever answered your question
um yeah
yeah come to the ground a new one
thanks again you'll come back to you
thank you Joe
um we've already heard that um the area
has a very small population
if you were able to take over the
premises at some stage as a community
could it be run viably
MJ Hughes hello
um specialists in valuing and
um
viability assessing
community-owned public houses
and
their reports tells us it's horrible
we wouldn't want to report that told us
it was viable that we didn't believe in
because we're the ones putting forward
the money
um can I do a supplementary question to
that please so how do you plan to run it
as a viable
business because it would need to be
that
um
you know are there going to be big
clinkers to it that you would plan to
make to enable it to be we don't think
that there are major changes the pub was
actually viable
um
prior to it closing
it had two bad years one of which was
when the land lady changed
they brought new people in and tried to
turn it into a kind of gastro pub which
just doesn't suit the situation it's in
prior to that it did really well you can
see the change of landlady if you look
at the turnover figures they dropped off
a cliff at that stage it made their
owner unpopular some people boycotted
the pup a lot of that trade will come
back
we don't need to make too many changes
to the structure of the building one
thing that the current land or I say
landlords current owners
pulled out the bar
which doesn't really bode well for the
the fact that they thought
that this happened I think
possibly less into their ownership they
pulled the bars out and lots of the
fittings downstairs
um so we just think that shows that
their intention from the start was that
this was going to be an investment
of the kind that Claire has just said we
don't want to see
thank you
thanks for others you had another
question
um yeah I was just wondering there's
local people whether you knew when it
was last lived in when the building was
last inhabited or whether anyone's
living there at the moment they live in
Australia at the moment
um there have been for I think around
about a year over the years they've come
and gone it's been kind of a family home
for some of that time but how much I
wouldn't know they don't really seem to
take any interest in the local community
I've spoken to them two or three times
in the course of the
12th or so years that they've lived
there
so so it hasn't been standing empty for
all of this time they are coming and
going yeah
yeah the downstairs is still the pub
area like upstairs
living area
thank you
thanks to McLaren you had another one
yes thank you chair Mr Smith actually I
was interested in the objections they
were quite widering I mean from a wide
area well out
shortly and Ipswich so and sailors
obviously can
more in a wooden Creek but I just wanted
to
ask you about your strategy because if
tourism is a is the main industry for
chocolate peninsula
what other
um competitors are there around Overton
um
we we don't think there are many
competitors of that kind
um
shortly Rose
is the nearest pub
um it's a bit basic it's not what we'd
be looking to to run
um
they will also
they were one of the two supporters of
the
um
application I believe and we think
that's
because I have a vested interest in not
having competition Road
um
the bikers aren't in half it's closed
down
as has
the companies at Holbrook so there are
two pubs in the area
which are
I Believe come see the Holbrook they're
trying to turn that into Flats
[Music]
um
the landlord of
the Quaker's arms we believe he's asking
far too much money for a tenant to move
in there and
well not on the market but up for rental
for considerable time so if I was coming
to
um
shortly as a tourist or on a bike
because we have a lot of lists and
workers
there really is very little for me to
stop and have some sort of refreshment
yeah there are other pubs around but
from the road
um
away from the thank you very much but I
think we're getting a little bit away
from the subject
Johnson register you had your hand
yeah and it sort of follows on from
memory question which is how busy is
that the road going through erberton in
terms of I'm
thinking in terms of passing trade for a
pub
and also as a would it if there is no
power
development
welcome to
Jesus yes
so this is a busy road you're asking in
general
it's not a busy road and that's part of
the Pub's appeal
um
it was always a destination Pub people
drove out there from that switch
um to have a meal
thank you very much thank you we now
have
the board member
councilor Davis you have five minutes to
address
the committee thank you chair
um first of all I'll just quickly talk
about the sustainability
um the Overton Queen was and would still
be very popular among cyclists because
while it's not a busy road it's a very
small Road cyclists love it for that
exact reason so the the trade would be
of cyclists and also Walkers if you look
at I think it's um the screen number
nine the slide number nine you can see
the proximity to Nest road which goes
down to the farm which goes down to
Irvington foreshore a very popular
walking route from shotley to Overton
and on to Holbrook Creek Hearthstone
Irvington Creek Holbrook Creek so and
again another attraction would be the um
the tourists in terms of Walkers and
cyclists a very important aspect the
other thing to point out while we're
talking about viability the pubs that
have closed as being mentioned were hard
commercial pubs this is more than just a
pub this is ideally going to be a Unity
facility is being pointed out that you
know the church is not ideal I know I've
been to the meetings there and as lovely
as it is you don't want to spend too too
long there so having a designated space
for the community is absolutely ideal
and it's exactly what baber's account
and the baber is a planning committee
to do we want to engage with our
communities we want to support our
communities and this this sort of
application turned in this grade two
building from a house to a from a house
into full residential you know is not
what the community want and it's not
what we as a council should be
supporting we should be supporting the
residents who have got this group
together they're well organized they've
got support from the Plunkett foundation
and many other National organizations so
I can see that working
reasons for refusal well they're in your
papers actually although
um
see it's recommended for refusal
um you can start paying well you start
with the em24 and the appeal that was um
give it and the and the Judgment there
was that it has the full employment
opportunities viability haven't been
fully explored now I totally understand
where where the officers come from the
economic growth and I can understand her
report because of the information she's
being given but you've seen today quite
clearly the employment opportunity
hasn't been fully explored because the
owners refused to engage with the
friends of shop of Overton Queen group
so so I would suggest that em24 hasn't
been completely satisfied and yes there
are a lot of anecdotes or I can give you
some as well I went in committee
um about the the lack of proper
marketing and lack of genuine desire to
make it go back into a pub that it just
wasn't done the owners you know In
fairness to them want to turn it into a
residential for their own reasons
um you know
the the Heritage officer has reported
about the Heritage aspects you know and
while on the outside as has been stated
probably not a lot of work would need to
be done certainly nothing structural
there's a large car park to help the pub
uh although like I say many people will
use it either cycling walking or walking
from within the village to get to get to
the pub but inside the damage that has
been done and the and the work if it
became a house would be extensive and
there are concerns that um about the
damage that would happen to a grade two
Pub inside if it were to be returned to
a bar
well exactly the bar counter would
return the rest would be cleaned up the
orange we would be used as the community
space as well as a restaurant
um so there would be no impact in terms
in terms of that if it became a pub the
rest is all on page 15 and 16 of your
papers you can see the principles of
development this is the retention and
development of accessible local services
and Community facilities I can go on but
you can read it for yourself this is one
they want to return it to a pub a once
thriving Pub they want to bring it back
for Community use and support economic
growth for baber in terms of the tourism
aspect
um and and basically put 3.2 3.3 the
rural economy
um should be sustained through a number
of measures and again this is one of
those measures you know we would argue
that it helps a rural economy to have a
thriving Pub and it supports the
community so a really important aspect
um the rest on there 3.5 3.6 3.7 they're
all reasons to refuse the the owner's
application and
um and therefore allow the community
group to come forward and give them
another offer have at least open a
dialogue because at the moment the
owners won't even talk to the group
um you can draw your own conclusion to
that
um yeah I've mentioned about the M24
I can't believe I've gone over thank you
very much
any questions for the moment
no
thank you
for now
move on
I will now
invite
the debate to begin
who would like to kick off
councilor beer
thank you Mr chairman well I certainly
listening to all the comments
um and the public speakers
I think we've all experienced public
houses in our areas that have closed I
have heard one very recently
closed we have a population of adults I
suppose about eight or nine thousand
pounds we have three pubs left in great
cornard so they're going there but some
of those pubs
uh don't open on a Monday some don't
open Monday and Tuesday
I find it very hard to believe that you
can make this pay in a village like
Irvington you say pass and trade is
likely to be cyclist or Walkers and what
have you
but I think being realistic
and we have to be realistic here that
um while there's all good intentions
they haven't come forward they haven't
got there this has been going backwards
and falls for years
I think the officers have done
all they can do
the marketing has been correct we've
been told that
um so I think at the end of all this I'm
going to propose Mr chairman the
officer's recommendation
yes I am proposed do I have a secondary
councilor Mabry seconded
right the whole park right any more
comments for anyone to make sure hope
yeah I disagree with Council beer and
Council Mabry actually I think it's it
should be within our gift to retain
these type of um pubs within our
communities they're an asset to them
they may only have 120 odd people but
they draw people in from a wider area I
think it's been noted about cycling
um
I think once you lose these out of the
community they're gone forever you'll
never get anything back to replace them
the life and soul of some communities
it's a shame that so many small hamlets
and Villages have lost their pubs over
the years so I'm a strong believer in
retaining these
establishments as I believe they have a
fundamental
um
meaning to to the uh rural communities
and the Health and Social benefit they
bring I think is immense
um I note that certainly the only thing
we seem to be um
I have against it is em24 and from what
I've heard so far yes they've complied
but it's very sketchy it's very vague in
in how they've done it
I don't really think that yes they've
complied to it it would appear but I
don't hold out a lot of confidence in
that the actual process involved in it
was was was good
and I certainly won't be supporting it
as I believe that we should be as I say
retaining these within our communities
there are huge benefit as I've said and
as I said I won't be supporting them
okay Council hold
ER register USD yeah
um I think this this case
um I'm not convinced that the marketing
was carried out an effective time and if
they if as we've heard they ripped out
all the pub infrastructure then it's not
going to appeal to anybody who might be
a wishing to turn it to purchase it as a
pub anyway because it's suddenly
increasing the costs for for any
potential purchaser which
um and that could have been done
my view is was that done on purpose or
not
um
I do think that what's clearly we need
to retain bubs in small villages because
they need a center
and if we keep losing them then we end
up losing communities in in villages and
that's
really not a good position to be in in
labor
um and if we if they can attract
tourists and cyclists which and that
area is
one of the areas that we would really
like to attract more cyclists and create
more cycling infrastructure I think it
could well be a good destination uh Pub
I am therefore minded to
um oppose
to recommend review refusal on this but
we already have a proposal on the table
at this moment in time so
if and when we've dealt with that we
make them back to you looking for
another slump thank you counselor
grandeur
thank you chair
um I'm minded not to support
um the current
um
proposal as well
um once it's gone it's gone
um it seems to me that the owners have
deliberately
allowed the or possibly have may have
enabled allowed the pub to fall into the
state that it's currently in
seems to me that the proposals from the
groups that we've heard from today
may have viability and I would like to
give them the opportunity I think if
they were to choose to do
a tourist accommodation as well that
would certainly
um give the premises
accounts have been becoming very viable
so I would like to think that we could
give them the opportunity to make it a
viable Community Asset and possibly a
strong business
thank you councilman can I just
absolutely clarify
clear
as far as the marketing is concerned
there is nothing the district council
can do further
no they
um and we had uh conversations with the
agent as well and were assured that
during that campaign no offer either
written or verbal was made
um
by the community group to the owners
during that period of campaign
Council McLaren you were next
yesterday chair some of us had the
benefit of listening to the leader in
the deputy leader share their Vision
with this new Administration and the
emphasis was
on the economy and thriving communities
and
um
I for me
stopping a business developing
is right and therefore I will not be
supporting the recommendation okay
thank you councilor hold yeah 12.6 on
the report sufficient marketing
information has been provided in this
instance to show the building is not
viable as a public house that's a bold
statement to make
not viable as a public house
really what em24 has decided to do not
viable as a public house that's a
statement that I think is Way Beyond it
it's meaning and um all it's saying is
that no one wants to pay the money for
it I don't think you can say it's not
viable as a public house we've got a
gentleman over here who quite clearly
believes it is viable as a public house
so I think that's the wrong wording in
there and I think it's misleading
Sam would you like to comment
Mark I was just going to say that that
is how the policy is framed um it should
be marketed for that and other
employment users actually look further
down and it was well we've done the um
the assessment and it was found not to
be so and therefore I think the word I
understand why you say that because
obviously people disagree but if we work
through what the policy says that is
thank you
anybody else councilor Mayberry
to vote on your motion yes thank you
thank you chairman um
this I have
visited this area quite a few times
so I would I would say that um that I do
know it
um I also have within my ward the
instances of public houses which have
either closed or we are hoping because
it's been refurbished that it will be
reopened but again
um there has not been a secure tenant
it is a difficult situation for the
hospitality trade Wherever You Are
um I also have within my ward which is a
huge tourist attraction
um instances of
accommodation not being fully booked at
this time
which is really unusual they are really
struggling some of them
um my decision to support the officers
is a we have to respect our officers
they have done their due diligence
they have looked at this
um and we have to respect their view we
can't just say we don't like it
um
I am the biggest Community person
probably in this room but I don't think
that this is viable and we may well be
better saying that this property goes
into residential use and perhaps it will
attract a family that will support the
surrounding infrastructure and whatever
that could possibly be
I know it's really sad but sometimes you
have to draw a line under this
because I really don't think that it is
viable as is suggested and I have loads
of experience
um with looking at the attractions of a
particular site
for something similar that has been
suggested here and it was deemed not
viable and it was a huge art gallery
thank you Mr chairman
as your councilor maybe councilor hold
I just want to come back to council
maybe um I don't think anyone here is
not respecting our officer's opinions
but we have our own and that's what
we're here to do to judge on our own
opinion so I'd just like to point that
that we do respect the officers but we
are here to judge it on our own merits
any more comments from anyone else
yeah can I just make a couple of points
before Memphis when you're gradually
summarizing what they're voting on yes
but I just want to clear up a couple of
points yeah um what I would advise
members is we've heard of the community
group and you know the sympathies for it
are understood but I would ask you
not to
allow the fact that there's a community
group and they'd like a bit more time
and all those things to inform your
decision it shouldn't be based on that
it should rather be based on a general
um
that
all marketing is needed it needs to be
done differently better just a general
approach to it rather than thinking
about the community group
the second point was there was a
suggestion it could be used for a
tourist accommodation Etc I mean that's
understood but that's that's not what
must be presented today so just stick to
the the principles of what's been
proposed and uh yeah over to you
thank you Mark can I now get you to read
out exactly what the voting will be on
yes it's as per the agenda chair and not
change at all by the type of papers so
the uh the motion is that the officer's
recommendation that change of use from
Sue generous to C3 dwelling house be
approved with the conditions which are
listed on pages 19 to
21 six conditions okay thank you okay
fine
we will now move to a vote Claire can I
get you to organize that
thank you chair members
that boat is now in progress
okay
that's no problem I can take your vote
verbally if you'd like
do you want to do that now
again thank you
my system's Frozen too hey no problem
can I take your vote verbally against
thank you
thank you member chair that is three
votes four and eight votes again
therefore that motion is lost thank you
so if I meet
um so that to State the obvious there's
now there's no authority to issue
planning permission but there's a
um and opposites don't necessarily
follow if there is to be a refusal there
would be a proposal I have to look for a
proposer and second or with reasons for
refusal which you may need some advice
the officers on or there are always
other options such as
postponing and asking for more
information on certain matters that's
what for members to to say what they
wish now
if I meet you yes you can
um I think memberships for you now to
decide what you want to do I think
really what you're asking us is is going
to tell us what you'd like us to do
um do you want us to take this away and
get a second opinion on the valuation do
you want us to
even ask for another period of marketing
which in our new policy would be and
reasonably would be six months now
what would you like us to do so have you
know debate amongst yourselves
Professor Davis um
can I just remind members that no
discussion regarding this if you're
going out the room thank you
okay right
you've now voted to refuse the
application
sorry you voted to refuse
from that proposal that was made
what we now have to do
is we either have to you have to give us
grounds for
the reasons for
not approving of it at this particular
stage or you've got the instructions
back to the planning offices as to what
you need to make another decision
as you keep expressing the fact that you
have doubts about some of the marketing
and viability
counselor do you want to keep yeah I
believe power 84 Power 93 cs17 cs15 cs21
all noted in the report are policies
that we hold within the within the
district within the council to support
and maintain and ensure that these type
of premises are kept within our
communities and I believe all these
policies apply in that we should
um
refuse as we already have done but I
would put those orders reasons for
refusal on on that basis and I'll also
add a comment that I believe the em-24
even though we've been told it has been
complied to I would like to see it
remarketed at um what I would consider
uh
a reasonable price but policy wise I
believe uh Power 84 para 93 CS 17 15 and
21 are reasons for us to do that
let's catch up with the plan in mind
and you added phones to apply for em24
as well was that correct
I take guidance on that because
obviously em24 we've been told has been
complied to technically my argument
would be that it is now a year ago
um and I would
question the market to campaign I know
we agreed it but I would also like us to
review our reasoning for that and uh
I would encourage us if we could
for it to be remarketed
as a reason for refusal well I'm
sticking to the ones I quoted you
I don't know whether members want to
debate
um
whether to just go for refusal or to
talk about the council Holt's second
point about the marketing and how you'd
like to see that done differently and
whether we should be allowed to take it
away and make sure that happens
it's my members to debate you
comments from anyone
cancel register your hand will not first
um yes in terms of being M20 em24 I
would I would my problem with it is the
timing
down and and when the the state of the
economy was in a very weird
entirely convinced that even if the
property had been in good good state of
repair and easily turned into a viable
Pub which I am also unconvinced by uh
that it would have achieved good
Marketing in the um in the state of
society and the economy at the time
because it was just at the end of
lockdown
thank you chair
um I agree with councilor Holton that if
um the owner
markets the property at such a high
price that no one's going to come and
purchase it at at
the the marketed price that they state
or they choose to have it for a property
that has been allowed to run down since
then obviously it's not going to achieve
the marketing aim
um so I think I don't know whether
as a council were allowed to get
involved in that element at all
um but I think a marketing campaign has
got to be reasonable and has got to be
workable as a true marketing campaign
not
um just the price that the owner wishes
to to achieve to enable them to meet
their own goals
um so I but I don't know how how you
know whether that is something that we
are
as an authority able to get involved in
perhaps that
um you can guide us please
yeah I mean in a sense we're already
happy because we've had the um internal
view on it saying that they you know
that they find
um they agree with the points raised but
obviously members you don't
so we could uh get a third party to
assess the marketing that's happened so
far and normally the applicant would pay
for that and we would choose who was
going to do it so it'd be neutral and
it'll be a third point of view on it
basically a fourth if you include the um
the friends of the Queen's head group uh
an independent view on it that would
mean there would be extra marketing now
we would just get an independent view on
whether the market has happened
was satisfactory
we could do that
Catherine
um
can can I ask advice please
um what does that then do to the
communities
involvement could you advise please
well if we were only if we were only
um looking at what's been done already
then then it wouldn't uh it wouldn't
change that at all basically just be
looking at what happened in that period
in time if however you wanted an extent
you know a further period of marketing
which would be six months then
interested parties be it the friends or
anybody else put in a reasonable bid
which was close to what was being asked
then that could be a game changer
Professor cop
okay
um I think that the whole marketing
needs to be looked at
as a whole whether it was done correctly
if an independent body could do that
um if it wasn't this is more of a
question I suppose if it wasn't could it
then be
redone for the 12-month period And if it
was could it then be extended to the
sixth period and also is it possible to
look at the valuation of the property to
see if it is being
marketed higher than what it's actually
worth
so lots of choices there basically
um I think we have to be fair to all
sides so I mean 12 months is a long time
but
if the marketing that's been done is
found to be faulty then I think we would
have to be in a position where they'd
have to to go again but the the joint
local plan policy which is gathering
weight as we speak uh By the time
we get to that it may be that we're
that's uh that policy has a lot more
weight and we may be looking at six
months rather than 12 months
um
and the other thing is if we just looked
at the value and the value is agreed by
the third party then we'd be in a
position coming back here saying well
actually
that was a fair thing
what do you think now members
so unless Claire wants to add anything
to those various choices but that's
things playing around in my mind are
another period of marketing which would
be a longer time
or somebody checking the assessment the
value which would be a shorter period of
time
thank you Mark
Sherman may I quickly yeah Ron
um I just
statement fairly obvious there's not a
reason why members shouldn't pass a
resolution that they wish to pass but
just I'm looking at the front page so
the expiry date for this is the 30th is
30th of June is that that's Friday isn't
it so the I mean the applicant
Liberty when we're out of time to appeal
against non-determination I'm not saying
they would do that and it's
not seeing as much of as we used to
because there's such a long wait for
planning appeals generally I think Mark
Mark and Harry would agree with that but
it's I'm just wishing to make the point
that it's not not a I'm not discouraging
members from passing any resolution they
want to but that it's we can't force the
applicant to wait the applicant to wait
for any period of time necessarily if
they choose to appeal against
non-determination when the time runs out
the I presume the Thrive at the
this wouldn't have been a 13-week one
would it Mark this would have been a
no no so anyway that'll be after the
30th of April sorry 30th of the sixth
month that is this Friday isn't it 30th
of June the applicant is present unless
they Grant an extension of time to us
there at Liberty to appeal
non-determination if they so choose as I
say they may choose not to but that
that's just something that I thought to
be really aware of yeah
thank you
Council register
uh just for clarification I I I I
remember that one of the officers
mentioned that the valuation was based
on comparables and having and knowing
that process well having worked for
childhood surveyors who were carrying
out valuations I know
exactly how imprecised that that is
because uh if you compare a derelict
building with a similar size building in
good repair or or a derelict pub with
one that's
viable and running busy there's no
comparison it's really hard to make a
comparison and
um so I'm yeah I think that needs to be
looked at is how the compare the
valuation and the and the comparables
was done because it's uh you just can't
take the number of rooms in the square
footage and do a comparison that way
because it's not it's not viable
thank you any comments
running statements submitted by the
applicants so there were three local
pubs that were on the market uh at a
price and excess of this one and
some others that had been sold
at prices that were slightly below this
one
and the agent's statement around the
basis for their pricing is part of the
planning application submitted by the
applicant
so you can see how they've arrived at
that
sorry
what should you want to raise
verification of her counselor halt give
reasons for refusal
those are on a seconder for the refusal
or did you do that and I missed it we
haven't done this yet and Council hasn't
made a proposal or do you want to make
it with that I thought I had I
guess sorry Council I thought you gave
two the two options about it
that made and I told you for refusal and
I said there is the additional bit of
that em24 but I'm not sure if we're
allowed to add anything onto that and
you open that up to the floor to discuss
that but I did actually make a proposal
so you have a proposal to refuse it on
para 84 93 CS 17 15 and 21. okay
thank you
sorry can I just confirm that that you
don't want em24 mentioned in the reasons
for refusal it's just those other
policies you mentioned at this stage
that was it then as you said we could
open up and talk about em25 which is
what we've been doing now we'd be
subsequently wanting additional and we
can vote on that your proposal won't
mention him 24 and not at the moment
unless members consider they want to add
to it
no
because we have a
proposing the second up
Mark can I get you to summarize what you
think that motion
saying yes
to refuse the application uh being
contrary to paragraphs 84 and 93 of the
mppf
and also being contrary to policies CS
17 15 and 21 of baber's core strategy
you're happy with that good
okay
thank you and Claire will you open up a
vote
the chairman members that vote is now in
progress thank you
The Grandin up have you been able to
look okay
and councilor Davies are you logged back
in now thank you
councilman Mabry sorry you're not
looking in anymore
no
oh okay sorry I didn't realize that can
I take your vote verbally then um well
it will be against because thank you I
don't agree with it thank you
thank you members chair that's
eight votes four and two against
before that application is refused
we are penciled in
the next meeting on
let's see trying to find these notes
12th the 12th of the next month
thank you very much for your attendance
meeting is closed